THIS, SERIOUS QUESTION, HASN'T
MUELLER EVEN HEARD OF MUELLER?
DONALD TRUMP JOINS US FOR HIS
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE THE
HEARING AND SCRAPE YOUR THANKS A
LOT FOR COMING ON.
SO, WHAT WAS --
I MEAN, I THINK THAT TWEET SUMS
IT UP PRETTY WELL BUT ELABORATE
ON WHAT YOU THOUGHT OF IT.
>> WELL, LISTEN.
I REALLY THINK IT DOES SPEAK FOR
ITSELF.
I MEAN, I'M WATCHING A GUY THAT
LED AN INVESTIGATION, WAS THAT
OF THE FBI, WAS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR, SPENT TWO YEARS AND
ALMOST $50 MILLION INVESTIGATING
IT AND A CONGRESSMAN ASKED,
LET'S TALK ABOUT FUSION GPS.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF IT APPEAR TO
ME, THAT BE LIKE A BUILDER
TALKING ABOUT NOT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT A FOUNDATION IS.
DO NOT EVEN HAVE A FINITE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS ALL
STARTED TELLS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
KNOW, TUCKER.
THIS WAS A HOAX SET UP BY THE
DEMOCRATS FROM MOMENT NUMBER
ONE.
IT WASN'T TRUE, THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS ABOUT TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
IT WAS TRYING TO BACK INTO THE
RESULT THAT THEY WANTED.
THEY COULDN'T DO THAT BECAUSE
THERE WAS NOTHING THERE.
BUT THEY DRUG PEOPLE THROUGH THE
MUD FOR TWO YEARS.
THEY SPREAD IT IN THE MEDIA,
AD NAUSEAM HIM, WITHOUT FAIL.
YOU SAW YOUR PRIOR GUESTS
EARLIER TODAY SAYING THE SAME
THING.
HE STILL MAY BE WORKING WITH
FOOD AND, YES, BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP NEEDED TO LEAVE HIS
LIFESTYLE OF LUXURY TO GO WORK
FOR THE RUSSIANS RATHER THAN,
BECAUSE HE'S SICK OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN AMERICAN POLITICS,
BECAUSE HE'S SICK OF
POLITICIZING EVERY SINGLE
ASPECTS AND BEING WILLING TO
RUIN PEOPLE'S LIVES, SEND
AMERICAN LIVES TO FIGHT WARS FOR
THINGS THAT DON'T EXIST, ALL OF
THIS NONSENSE THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT, BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FINALLY SAW IT.
THAT THIS MAN, WHO WAS THE LEAD
OF THE LARGEST INVESTIGATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, REALLY THE
LARGEST HOAX AT THIS POINT, HE
DIDN'T HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
UNDERSTANDING OF NOT ONLY WHERE
IT BEGAN, BUT WHAT WAS EVEN
INVOLVED.
HOW IT TOOK PLACE.
ULTIMATELY, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SAW THAT HE WAS PUT IN
THERE AS A FIGUREHEAD BECAUSE HE
WAS A FORMER LEADER OF THE FBI,
HE WAS A DECORATED MARINE AND HE
WOULD DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
BUT, NO ONE'S TALKING ABOUT THIS
GUY PUT IN 19 LEFT IS
HILLARY CLINTON DONOR LAWYERS.
THEY WORKED ON THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, THEY WENT TO HER, WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HER INAUGURATION
PARTY.
THEY WOULD'VE CELEBRATED IT.
HE WOULD HAVE NO IDEA IT WAS
RUNNING THE SHIP.
ANIMATES WERE RUNNING THE ASYLUM
AND AS INMATES FOR THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY WHO WERE DOING WHATEVER
THEY COULD TO DESTROY MY
FATHER'S PRESIDENCY BECAUSE THEY
SEE THAT HE'S ACTUALLY GETTING
THINGS DONE.
HE'S ACTUALLY GETTING THINGS
DONE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE'S ACTUALLY DELIVERING ON THE
PROMISES THAT HE MADE.
AND WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE AS
AN AMERICAN, AND SOMEONE WHO HAS
REALLY BEEN DRUGGED THROUGH THE
MUD MYSELF IN HIS WHOLE HOAX,
IS, I'D LOVE TO SEE THE
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
FOR AMERICANS FOR CHANGE.
NOT FOR THEIR POWER BASE, NOT
FOR THE POLITICAL ELITE, NOT FOR
THEIR NONSENSE CRAZY THAT THEY
ARE RUNNING WITH THESE DAYS BUT
FOR ACTUAL HARDWORKING
AMERICANS.
HOW ABOUT GETTING THE USMCA
PASSED THROUGH CONGRESS QUESTION
MIKE ABOUT WORKING ON AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL?
HOW ABOUT DOING ANYTHING OTHER
THAN TRYING TO DESTROY MY FATHER
WHO IS ACTUALLY DELIVERING FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT HE SAID HE WOULD
DELIVER FOR?
ALL AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: TWO THINGS,
JERRY NADLER IS ON ANOTHER
CHANNEL RIGHT AS WE SPEAK SAYING
MORE SUBPOENAS SO, THIS WILL,
APPARENTLY, POURING ACCORDING TO
MR. ANOTHER, CONTINUE.
WE SURPRISED TO HEAR THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE COME NANCY PELOSI
COME AND SAY THIS AFTERNOON TO
US THAT SHE STILL BELIEVES THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS WORKING FOR
RUSSIA?
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> NO, BECAUSE THIS IS ALL THEY
HAD.
THEY HAVE DEIGNED TO THEIR
ENTIRE REPUTATION ON A PAIRED
MEMBER AND STARTED OFF AS
COLLUSION, THAN I WAS GOING TO
BE CONSTRUCTION, THAN IT A
COVER-UP, THEN IT'S GONNA BE
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK.
THEN, MUELLER IS GOING TO BE THE
SAVIOR, WE ARE GOING TO GET IN
THIS TIME, THEY JUST KEEP
DOUBLING DOWN.
AGAIN, BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE IS
WILLING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE YOU, MAYBE SEAN
AND THE NEXT HOUR, A FEW PEOPLE,
BUT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WILL
STILL BUY IN LARGE RUN WITH JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING THAT THEY SELL
THEM.
THEY DON'T HALF TO BE
FACT-BASED.
THERE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE ANY
EVIDENCE.
AS LONG AS THEY SAY IT, THAT'S
ALL THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS BECOME THE
DE FACTO MARKETING DIVISION OF
THE DFC.